[Música]
o maior desafio que temos na segurança
pública é a mentalidade é a forma de
olhar a realidade é que a gente possa
enxergar as soluções é preciso mudar o
enquadramento da vida social é preciso
mudar o modo de enxergar o outro ea si
mesmo e poder então descobrir que as
soluções de segurança estão ao alcance
de nossas mãos para isso é preciso então
romper preconceitos pré concepções em
favor de alguma coisa que é sentir a dor
dos outros ter compaixão e é isso que
nós vamos mostrar aqui ok vamos nós pra
começar nós demandamos segurança mas nos
oferecem proteção o que é a proteção
proteção e segurança
não há proteção e desigual seletiva
excludente discricionária e paga se por
ela a com segurança a proteção desculpa
é produzida a partir do medo quando mais
e maximiza o medo fábricas insegurança
diante do medo nós vamos perdendo a
nossa capacidade de sustentar os nossos
direitos e diante das ameaças
multiplicados por essa fabricação de
medos e de crises
o tempo inteiro na segurança nós vamos
em busca de um fortão de ocasião de um
milagreiro de um falso profeta que nos
prometeu salvar no imediato que prometa
uma solução perfeita mas não a solução
na segurança que não nos envolva todas
antes do acerto da ação de segurança é
como se fosse uma espécie de eterno
defunto que só o defunto usa porque ele
não tem mais o que reclamar correto
então diante do medo que é péssimo
conselheiro nós vamos abrir mão das
garantias individuais e coletivas em
favor do fortão de ocasião que os
planetas proteção no imediato o fato é
que esse protetor de agora será o
achacador o tirano de amanhã será aquele
que vai cobrir uma fatura uma nota
promissória que não temos como pagar
e é disso que nós vamos falar para
romper com os paradigmas da segurança
nós precisamos entender como nego o que
de fato produz e com a diferença ea
proteção que nos é oferecida no brasil e
seus rendimentos políticos e
o que é segurança pública que tal
alcance das suas mãos
o primeiro ponto a ser dito é que o
fundamento da lógica da proteção ea
sustentação ea fabricação indefinida de
ameaças
isso faz com que a nossa vida os nossos
direitos o direito à vida o direito à
liberdade o direito à igualdade
o direito à propriedade sejam moedas de
troca
diante da falácia da fabricação
artificial da segurança produzida pela
lógica pelos negócios da proteção e como
isso funciona para isso a gente tem que
romper um determinado paradigma e para
romper paradigmas tem que entender
porque quanto mais a gente se protege
mais inseguro a gente sente e aqui vamos
fazer um exercício rápido de simulação
jaqueline eu me sinto insegura
completamente ameaçada eu me sinto
sozinha entregue a mim mesmo e deus por
ninguém
eu não consigo fechar meus olhos eu vejo
ameaça para todos os lados todos os
lados estão me colocando em risco em
perigo eu preciso fazer alguma coisa a
saída e lumiar ma eu preciso irmã para
me defender de você você pode me
projetar tira tudo o que é meu
você também para novamente pensa a mesma
coisa que iam você se a água porque acha
ele acredita que em breve irá empregar
você atacar tira tudo que você tem
e assim seguimos nessa corrida
armamentista
eu me amo pra me defender de você você
se arma para se defender de mim e se
demos todos quanto mais armados mais
inseguros porque mais inseguros porque
na corrida armamentista
nessa guerra fria que nós construímos
entre o eu eo outro nesta guerra fria
nós estamos em condições desiguais
entrega nós mesmos só assim os
solitários não têm confiança
experimentando a suspensão ampliada a
desconfiança criada como se cada um de
nós fosse elemento suspeito do outro e
dessa maneira nós estamos sempre em
desvantagem diante da ação do outro se
você tem um carro blindado em algum
momento você vai ter que sair nem que
for pra fazer xixi se você por acaso
comprou câmeras de vídeo e brindou a sua
casa com câmeras de vídeo de alguma
maneira você vai precisar que os
recursos públicos de segurança cheguem
com a presteza em menos de cinco minutos
e menos de dez minutos senão você vai
ser refém da polícia depois da polícia
do filmou da polícia
depois que aconteceu isso mostra que por
um lado o tempo inteiro quanto mais a
gente se a arma mas coletivamente
estamos inseguro e porque estamos em
seguro o que estamos em permanente
desvantagens
o recurso à força o recurso com esse
objetivo é o recurso caro nobre escasso
quando você usa para se defender o
primeiro momento 9 segundo em seguida
você estará vulnerável você estará
aberto à toda sorte de ataque pela
impossibilidade que nós temos de
estabelecer equivale ncia do recurso de
força cada um aqui tem um capital
político econômico cultural diferenciado
que nos impede de produzir a acumulação
do armamento para proteção individual e
mais não é possível não fechar os olhos
é impossível ficar o tempo todo em
estado de alerta vai ser quando a gente
abaixar as guardas vai ser quando a
gente olhar para o lado e eu com um
direito nosso foi embora e que serão
hospedados portanto a fantasia do
circuito perverso da proteção essa
retórica e disse que armar a melhor
solução
na verdade nos coloca o tempo todo refém
dessa fatura dessa nota promissória que
cada um tem que pagar e não consegue
produzir porque como é que funciona a
economia política da proteção ela
depende da maximização da ampliação da
ameaça para seguir obrigando a gente
acompanha pretas com a proteção isso
quer dizer que o tempo inteiro o nosso
protetor voluntarismo de hoje seja ele o
musculoso simpático que te protege seja
traficante gente boa seja miliciano
prestativo o fortão da academia todos
eles de alguma maneira vou te cobrar uma
taxa manhã uma taxa de vida uma taxa da
sua liberdade uma taxa da sua igualdade
uma taxa do seu direito à propriedade e
portanto você está confinado numa
espécie de cercadinho vip sem ter
mobilidade alguém servindo de
despachante da sua vontade de
despachante dos seus direitos e
despachante da sua esperança na
despachante da sua escolha como é que
funciona então esse circuito perverso da
proteção todos nós estamos o tempo todo
sentindo ameaçados essas ameaças são
indefinidamente fabricadas o que leva a
cor dos precários de um contrato vale o
contrato de agora vai ser derrubado
daqui a pouco porque cada um que
assegura a espada
a cabeça do outro isso leva a uma
espécie de governo vulnerável de comando
instável que vai produzir tirania
essas ironias vou fazendo uso do terror
do exemplar smo do espetáculo e do
justiçamento como forma publicitária de
maximizar o medo maximizaria a ameaça e
com isso seguir vendendo e sujeitando
pela lógica da proteção
com isso se fabricam guerras guerras
artificiais sobretudo guerra às drogas
já que não se faz guerra contra objetos
e cinco outras pessoas e as drogas que
serve como cortina de fumaça para
maximizar a insegurança coletiva por
isso temos uma espécie de crimes
tentação barulhento
de outro lado a polícia barulhenta que a
fábrica e ajuda fabricar essa
insegurança para atender propósitos
particulares e sabotam os recursos
públicos de segurança inclusive a
própria segurança do agente da lei
essa fabricação de medos ampliadas vão
fortalecendo o clamor social uma demanda
o apetite por cada vez mais punição por
cada vez mais vigilante zta o que nos
leva a acreditar que governar e proteger
no entanto proteger não é pra todos era
para augusto o que quer dizer que se
hoje você tá do lado de cada cerca
amanhã você pode estar do lado de lá e
quem garante não há garantias porque não
há como fechar contratos não há como
contar com a solidariedade de ninguém
você está entregue a si mesmo assim o
próprio medo refém dessa dinâmica e quem
é que ganha com isso e quais são os
efeitos perversos dos senhores da guerra
que nada mais são do que os mercadores
de proteção experimentamos no brasil de
uma maneira geral os negócios da
proteção eles têm uma dinâmica própria
que ultrapassam esse imediato que a
gente costuma observando a realidade
na verdade governa-se aqui com o crime e
não contra ele
algum de vocês aqui assina uma
procuração e aberto algum de vocês
assina um cheque em branco então porque
entregamos o principal poder não poder
de co de controle social o poder de
regulação social de administração das
regras do jogo para aqueles que fazem
promessas e gravatas mas que são
incapazes de garantir a segurança do ir
e vir a segurança de todos uma segurança
de sobrenome público o que acontece com
a polícia quando estamos diante do jogo
dos negócios da proteção a primeira
dimensão é de vulnerabilização do polis
ele tem que ser conivente convivente o
conveniente com essas lógicas
predatórios particularistas do poder o
que isso significa na prática isso
significa que o policial tem vários
padrões que o tempo todo e se os patrões
têm cabeças que não obedece umas às
outras de tal maneira que o tempo todo
nós assistimos da rua bateção de cabeça
de um lado e desacatos e abuso de
autoridade o tempo todo diz autorizações
continuados nesse círculo vicioso o mais
vulnerável é o policial que vir uma
moeda de troca e policiais mortos no
enfrentamento na falsa guerra quanto se
do quanto o crime servem de palanque
eleitoral e as mortes dos civis seguem
de publicidade mórbida para sustentar a
indústria da insegurança e o que
funciona observa que não há como
construir governos autônomos vinculados
ao crime
se não tiver as cenas de dentro de
setores do próprio estado isso significa
administrar bicos privilégios que em
telas o que faz com que os policiais
honestos tem que se calar para sustentar
seu próprio emprego porque de um lado
eles ganham a carteira de polícia e de
outro atestado de óbito se tornando um
bis de patrulhamento mortos-vivos a
aguardar o seu fim
o seu fim de matar véu porque eles vêm
do mundo popular daqueles que moram
longe que não são brancos que não sou da
alta classe média e como é que funciona
o mercado da proteção então se vende de
tudo tudo se cobra taxa desde a taxa
devida ao gato net a banda larga à luz o
estado funciona como uma espécie de
agência reguladora do crime a produzir
franquias ocupacionais e consórcios de
tal maneira que rende uma economia
milionária isso quer dizer que as terras
fabricadas entre facções guerras entre
facções a polícia serve como espécie de
dia trabalhar e dady operacional a escom
produzir a exceção lugar da rotina
a excepcionalidade no lugar da ida da
regra é possível viver sem regras do
jogo é possível jogar o futebol se não
se conhece as regras do jogo e como isso
rebate nós estamos ali no cotidiano
vivendo sendo induzidos a levar um mundo
solitário de desconfiança e suspensões
de todos contra todos experimentamos
nesse mundo da sociedade que chama o
dislike quem ama
quem é quem ama odeia quem ama exclui
somos levados a produção do regime de
imposição de regras onde cada um de nós
para dar moral e produz verdade sobre o
outro como se fossemos corretores
sensores jogadores na sobre a realidade
sobre a vida do outro
o que isso implica no cotidiano e prevê
que cada um dê não é solitário nossas
próprias razões nos elegemos como fita
métrica de corte sexo de raça de gênero
e orientação sexual a poder bater no
peito a criar a chamada síndrome da
pequena unidade
na prática isso vira uma coisa chamada
escolar sobre a cia tudo nós
experimentamos a destituição na esquina
da nossa cidadania que passasse uma
cidadania sob tutela uma cidadania que
depende de despachante uma cidadania que
depende de procurador uma cidadania de
carnê que o tempo tudo que você tem que
pagar para garantir os seus direitos
fundamentais
não é isso leva apetites ponit vistas e
predatório de ordem como essa ordem não
nos pertencem fosse extra ordinária e
não ordinária do cotidiano
vocês excepcional e não rotineiro o que
faz com o tempo todo nós ficamos
assustados enquanto eu olho pra vocês
algum direito nei está sendo perdido
algum direito nei está sendo tirado é
deus meus direitos que a deus meus
direitos
ok e é essa experimentação quanto mais
assustados mas sozinhos mas confinados
nas nossas nos nossos cercadinhos vips
mas somos vítimas individuais e grupais
da fabricação artificial de segurança a
insegurança experimentamos antes de ser
um problema na escola é uma decisão
política é um projeto de poder
o projeto de poder que visa e se essa
dimensão continuada e de instituição
ok seguindo como então podemos seguir
produzindo segurança a segurança pública
a primeira dimensão é a confiança quanto
mais e maximiza confiança mas é um meio
eficaz eficiência e efetividade de
polícia quanto mais se multiplica por
fiança mas é possível desenhar regras
comuns que possam ser fiscalizadas é
possível torcer um futebol se você não
conhece as regras se você não sabe
distinguir uma falta de um pênalti um
gol como jogar um jogo democrático
republicano da segurança pública se não
é regra
o jogo fica valendo o peito de pombo da
autoridade da ocasião
portanto das lógicas de mandonismo a que
experimentamos e dissertados que
reproduzem privilégios como jogar o jogo
democrático da produção de obediência a
distinção do que é a produção de
obediência às regras do jogo dos
mecanismos autoritários despóticos
excludentes de sujeição né isso depende
de produziu as regras do jogo para serem
fiscalizados sócia polí cia a partir de
regras só se regula a partir de regras
públicas pactuadas o que são regras
legítimas aquelas que todos concordam o
que são regras legais
aquelas que valem para todos e essa
condição de polícias possibilidade para
que a polícia possa exercer o seu lugar
o seu lugar de produção de tentativas
pacíficas e obediência sobre as regras
do jogo diante do império da lei e sob
consentimento social e que é com o
sentimento social é sentir junto é
articular um projeto comum da sociedade
diferente do que tem sido sido vendidos
como mercadoria e transformados a nossas
vidas nem demonstração de um espetáculo
macabro publicitário e só retro alimenta
a indústria da insegurança a conivência
ea convivência de setores estatais com a
dinâmica da insegurança e portanto da
proteção o que nós temos é o que
funciona na segurança paz com pais o que
funciona no rio na segurança
previsibilidade o que funciona na
segurança o arroz eo feijão o arroz eo
feijão que está pouco o resumo o arroz
com feijão do policiamento o
policiamento da pronta resposta da
presteza da emergência o policiamento da
produção ostensiva de polícia da
cobertura extensiva a produção de
policiamento através da actividade
integrada de inteligência investigação e
policiamento das operações policiais que
são diferentes da síndrome do cabrito do
sobe-e-desce morro das operações
policiais que existem para reduzir a
incerteza o risco ou perigo real
aqui estamos em pó expostos e o cidadão
eo policial adão policial também é essa
esse arroz com feijão essa banalidade na
rotineira e produz a solução daqui agora
por aqui há pouco recuo - fazer mais e
melhor
mas por que será que isso não é
investido porque será que isso é
abandonado e se abandonado porque têm
rendimentos políticos
e os rendimentos políticos é que quando
a espada que autonomiza ela corta pra
todos os lados não é a própria espada
que define o ao seu alcance a
profundidade do seu corte o que
distingue as formas de corte por exemplo
retrô açougueiro nã e o cirurgião é a
precisão e finalidade do corte mas que
isso o que pensei quem desenha não é a
arma que desenha minha mão e desenho meu
pensamento é o pensamento a decisão
escolhe o modo de agir diante dos meios
nação e sua logística de polícia
portanto os armamentos que da polícia
superioridade de meios e métodos capaz
de responder diante do nosso imediato do
nosso medo diante do imediato da nossa
segurança diante do imediato do perigo
que estamos experimentando no cotidiano
ok isso significa e segurança pública é
muito mais do que a intensidade
exclusividade o qualidade da ação
policial segurança pública envolve todos
nós e pra fechar eu diria pra vocês uma
coisa fundamental se o vigia é fraco
demais
ele se vende o primeiro da esquina c é
forte demais
ele senta na cadeira do golpe e governo
em seu lugar
é bom lembrar que a espada entregue a si
própria ou manipulada por aqueles que
têm um projeto de poder para atender os
seus apetites particulares tempo razão
básica cortar a língua do verbo de
qualquer verba da política de qualquer
verba do governo e rasgar os termos da
lei faça você mesmo a sua segurança
pública pessoas hoje a segurança pública
em joão pessoa estão ao alcance de joão
pessoa estão ao alcance da paraíba
não nos faltam competências capacidades
o que não falta é compaixão e
generosidade e vontade de agir junto de
produzir esse lugar que é de todos com
uma segurança cujo sobrenome é público
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]